prosecutors say they will not charge any
police officers officers in the death of
amir lock in early february the 22 year
old was killed in an apartment as
minneapolis police officers carried out
a no knock search warrant he was killed
by officer mark hanneman who returned to
active duty less than a month later his
death led to massive protests at the
time now locke's mother is reacting to
the decision tarika duncan is following
all of this darika good morning good
morning obviously the mother not happy
about that decision this announcement
actually came one day after the
minneapolis mayor announced a city-wide
ban on no knock warrants minnesota's
attorney general said emir lock was a
victim not a suspect and might be alive
today if that warrant had never been
executed but he also said state law
would not support charges against
officer hanneman
because it seems like it's just us
acting for just us every year just us
community leaders rallied in minneapolis
on wednesday it is completely hurtful to
the community after prosecutors declined
to charge officer mark hanneman for
shooting and killing amir lock we would
not be able to prove in court
that officer henneman's use of force was
not authorized under the law beyond a
reasonable doubt minneapolis police were
searching for locke's cousin makai
camden speed in connection with the
homicide when they executed the no knock
warrant in the early morning body cam
video shows a minneapolis swat team
using a key to enter the apartment where
locke was sleeping
officers are heard shouting with their
guns drawn lock appears to be sleeping
on the couch before rising with a gun in
his hand officer hannemann then shoots
locke three times
about 10 seconds after entering
prosecutors determined hannemann was
justified in firing his weapon although
his finger was not on the trigger that
gun was pointed directly at officer
handman
i am not disappointed i am disgusted
with the city of minneapolis at a news
conference wednesday locke's mother
karen wells along with attorney ben
crump and reverend al sharpton vowed not
to give up the pursuit for justice
you may have been found not guilty
but in the eyes of me being the mother
who i am you are guilty the spirit of my
baby is going to hunt you for the rest
of your life
in a statement the police officers
federation of minneapolis said they used
deadly force by an officer is never used
rather of a deadly force by an officer
is never taken lightly and weighs heavy
on the officers involved now the
incident was a tragedy for everyone
involved and will have a lasting impact
on many lives locke's family says while
criminal charges are now off the table
they may pursue civil action so that's
not surprising because as they said
they're searching for for justice in
this case and feel like their son should
still be here it's also a very
complicated case too you know when you
look at keith ellison in his record he's
a very well respected very thorough very
good at what he does and to hear him say
that he's clearly saying he doesn't
think he could win this case so why
would he go forward with it on the other
hand you have a mirror who's licensed to
carry the gun is my understanding
so you have that but
they bust in he doesn't amir lock
doesn't know who these people are and
what is happening yeah it's it's very
very very complicated
it's unfortunate
all the way all the way around
all the way around
that's not the end of it either thank
you